I don't think people understand how  practical karma is I actually think it's  the single most practical thing in the  world I think it's just a genuine belief  that the more selfless you are capable  of being the more likely what you want  selfishly will happen and I think that's  just a point of view that's a  perspective a leap of faith I think all  of us are byproducts of our environment  our DNA how we were parented and we all  go different tracks and I think that  most people unfortunately come from a  place of scarcity and thus they're  trying to hoard for themselves I think  when you're blessed or lucky enough to  come from a place of abundance what  you're talking about becomes very easy  it's just how I see the world I think  that the more one can lean into giving  back in all shapes and sizes the more  that the world will keep them propped up